so you guys gonna help me win the game
we won't win the game together you're
not gonna help me win the game you won't
be in a stadium dad's uncles aunts
brothers sisters mothers cousins bro
look you're not helping anymore bye-bye
good for everybody never lose money
quit investing in stocks quit
speculating quit Bitcoin in whatever you
have to do to keep your purpose burning
hot you do it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results need motivation watch the
top 10 with believe nation what's that
belief nation at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level of talent
at something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from being in the
drug rehab clinic at age 25 to 5 years
later being a self-made millionaire to
now owning over half a billion dollars
in real estate
he's Grant Cardone and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 8 also
if you want to know a grant and other
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
free video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long to help you build your
confidence check out the link in the
description below where do you get your
self-confidence you can buy it at the
store folks can't dress it up can't eat
it
you can't buy it you can't even
manufacture it yourself you have to go
build self-confidence
ok let's get it off with rule number one
aim high number one if you want to
become a millionaire number one you have
to decide to become a multimillionaire
you were going to miss calculate the
zeros and this is what the 10x rule was
the 10x rule was a multiplier you must
multiply in order to add you have to
learn how to do something a lot of times
to ever get good at it for Sabrina to be
good at one of those things you do
cartwheels she's gonna do thousands tens
of thousands of cartwheels to finally be
able to stay on one line so that's the
same thing for the ballerina same thing
for LeBron I have to do something ten
thousand times before I'll ever make a
billion dollars or 100 million or ten
million you got to get great edit folks
frequencies away to greatness number one
decide to become a multimillionaire not
a millionaire one go for multi
millionaire status go for the multi
status okay if you want ten if you want
one go for 10 if you want ten go for a
hundred decide on a multiple fail high
rather than setting a target that later
you find out was too low rule number two
stop all poverty behavior number two
stop all poverty behavior poverty is a
terrible thing if you've ever known
anybody lived in poverty suffer with
poverty even close to the poverty line
you know that it is awful and even those
with money can live like they are in
poverty I've known millionaires that
acted like they were in poverty wouldn't
spend any of the money they had because
they were worried about money not coming
in in the future make a list of all the
actions because most of this is mental
make a list of all action those who live
in poverty operate with and commit to
not doing them listen to what I'm saying
here make a list of the activities that
people that either live in poverty or
act like they're living in poverty how
they operate everyday
drugs alcohol buying stuff not investing
but spending wasting weekend's
government or any kind of dependence
upon others shortcuts victim mentality
not reading refusing the network
and refusing to get outside your zip
code and travel or all things that you
need to stop and I'm sure you could
expand this list
stop all poverty behavior rule number
three expand 12 employees I'm sure at
one point you had you know four or five
employees had to go through four or five
- whatever you have to do now I had I
had two employees from the age of 29 no
no from the age of 30 to 38 years old I
had two employees for eight years I did
everything I was the secretary phone
answer I did payroll stole for myself
did my taxes I did my own taxes I
wouldn't pay anybody anything okay from
32 to 38 38 to 45 added like two or
three people I was I was officing out of
the guest house
at my my place that I lived at in in Los
Angeles
[Music]
it was a dude it was an awesome a Lionel
Richie lived in that house a you know it
was a cool house right but it was small
thinking man I was still thinking little
and if you're gonna stay smart you're
gonna get crushed for sure yes 2009 2008
and 2009
so what eventually made you say you know
what
what happened was a guy told me years
before that that bigger is not better
and I believed it because he busted out
he busted out when he went big and he
says grant bigger is not better man stay
small and I and I believed that dude and
I carried it on a long time bad advice
knowledge is power
bad knowledge is too so what I did was I
stayed small till I was 45 years old
five employees I was one of them so four
and when 2008 came on like this was
stupid dude like I got a scale and and
that was what 12 how many years ago was
that nine you're seven seven or eight
years ago there was no jet
it was no big office they just shows you
man when you change your mind when you
change your mind and start like hey I'm
gonna scale this thing out I'm gonna go
global I'm gonna have people know me I'm
gonna get attention I'm gonna get my
products out I'm gonna lower my prices
I'm gonna bring this thing to market I'm
gonna get big bringing good people we
have how many employees we have now
charity 272 at the office we got our
partners here tonight
we got an another 150 and again in the
real estate game we're gonna expand that
we'll probably pick up another 12 or 15
this month because the two more deals
we're bringing on and next year I'm
talking about going global so oh
everything that happened everything
that's happened really good to us has
happened because of the expansion rule
number four be the solution not the
problem when I'm in a deal and the
problems there I will I will nag on it
and create some drama just a problem
this is a problem this is a problem but
I'm like okay what are we gonna do about
it
like I want to get to the solution now
let's drop it I don't even Harvey Harbor
I'm doing a deal right now one of the
biggest deals in my whole life yeah and
this guy promised to do one thing then
found out he couldn't and I want to
punch him in the face well I want him I
want to punish him for it I want him to
like I want to crucify him a bit over it
right and then I'm like I even want to
tell him I'm not gonna do the deal even
though I know the deal is good for me
right and then I'm like I got to put
that up do the deal that's the solution
let's move on we did okay I think that
what I've done is I've basically taken
the things that bother me and turn them
around like you know I didn't have an
uncle so I'm like hey why don't you quit
saying how you didn't have an uncle and
be the uncle I hated the car business so
I'm like rather than quitting the car
business and walking away from it why
don't you make the car business better
so I don't like the way little little
people are treated with their finances
how the bank's treat you the poor Oh
Caze find a house all the scam so I'm
like you know what I can't just be about
something without becoming part of the
solution so that's why I'm pretty sure
that's why we created Cardone capital
rule number five pay attention to money
I was 51 years old between the age of 25
and 51 I didn't have one drink sitting
until I get my money so right I don't
deserve a hangover I'm not having any
more hangovers those hangovers cost you
money right how many of you will cope
with a hangover today paid attention to
it for the first two hours how good you
feel man how good you feel how confident
you are it takes a lot of confidence to
go get money it takes a lot of
willingness and determination you know
it's not a problem when you're broke
it's a problem when you get money when
you start having a little bit of money
that's where most people soften up would
you agree how often do I look at my
finances every day man I say send me
that if you got one checking account
with $3,000 in it look at it if you
don't look at it it if you ignore it it
will go away money loves attention
money is like a it's like a jealous
lover you don't pay attention to it it's
gonna find somebody else to bed with
rule number 6 create multiple flows of
income number six create multiple flows
of income it is said that the average
millionaire has seven flows of income
that's not true I assure you the rich
boys and girls have many many more flows
than seven I probably have closer seven
hundred then I do seven multiple flows
never rely on one flow of anything okay
and by the way those of you out there
quit your job you're like I'm not your
didn't quit your job you left your job
you start a network marketing and you
gave the network marketing more
attention than your first job now you're
back to one job okay the reason you got
a network marketing is to great get to
flows of income going
don't leave the first one go to the
second one abandon the first one you end
up with one again multiply rule number
seven get rid of negativity iron
people's not the problem get rid of this
okay and I don't care if we get rid of
thank you like I don't remember any of
them I tell my wife all the time they
might all go so we might just nuke them
cuz we're gonna go win the game so you
guys gonna help me win the game we're
gonna win the game together you're not
gonna help me win the game you won't be
in a stadium and that's the way it is
brothers sisters uncles aunts I like you
I love you we spooned it once whatever
dude
if you that was okay if you're not
helping us move the ball down the field
you're gonna go dads uncles aunts
brothers sisters mothers cousins bro
look you're not helping anymore bye bye
good for everybody
right if you've ever drugged somebody
along and they weren't in the game
anymore when you let them go they're
happy about it later too pissed off in
the beginning and then they're like man
thanks a lot man
I wasn't shipping it anymore was I so I
know I can see that some of your
thinking right now man I got to get rid
even your friends dude you're already a
company everybody here already has a
company you are a company right now you
don't get a company you are a company
all the friends you got the leeches
losers right the bad advice givers all
the [ __ ] that you put up with every
day all the bad advice you get all the
freaking stealing going on around you
the person that works across the desk
from you that steals hours from your
owner that talks a negative about your
owner the guy that's writing him a check
and he's like hey what a what a wanker
he is right and you listen all that all
that's affecting you that is your
company right now rule number eight
never lose money number eight
never lose money period when I invest in
a relationship and I take a client to
dinner I cannot lose that money the
money goes away from me and I get the
relationship they remember I remember
right when I put Daymond John on my
plane and fly him across Las Vegas it
would appear that I lost money Daymond
remembers I remember we talked about it
and it pays me in the future never lose
money okay I get on a plane fly across
the country my wife and I and the kids
and we fly over there we have great
memories that money is lost don't kid
yourself okay great memories and my kids
you should have brought somebody with
you think bigger what you ought to do is
bring a family that could do business
with you that can advance your network
you would be better off spending ten
times more money than less money and
having an investment never lose money
quit investing in stocks quit
speculating quit Bitcoin in I mean until
you're rich don't play that game never
lose money rule number nine go all-in
I'm 19 years old
right now I noticed a stuff and I had
only about 60 grand up and 200 grand to
the u.s. tubular steel yeah hello you
had to see great like you got to get the
other forty bro it's an arbitrary number
I just made up the number it could be a
hundred and ten it could be it it's just
it's just so you know first of all when
you get to 100 - call me and then I'll
probably tell you hey man you need to
wait till you got 350 but at least then
you're gonna be like you know what I
learned how to make I learned how to not
just make 100 save 100 and put a hundred
away people are investing too soon there
you guys are investing 3 grand here 2
grand over here a thousand bucks five
hundred you're walking away from it it's
never worth any money is dumb and you
never create the discipline what you end
up with is a bunch of losses a bunch of
little losses rather than knowing I have
the confidence that I can make money set
it aside protect it right protect it
like a kid right
it's not gonna get in a wreck I don't
lose it I would do that first so is
there an age I didn't invest my first
investment was $5,000 then I blew it and
I'm like I'm not doing that again
my next investment is gonna be big where
I'm gonna watch it because if it's big
enough dude if your life depends on it
you'll get up in the morning Jen you'll
watch it so my next deal was 350 grand
it took three years to do it all I did
was save money save money save money I
put 350 grand in the deal
so that deal for four million dollars
four million dollar profit I had I had
one-third of all my money in that deal I
had a million dollars like a million one
put 350 in my first deal 30 days later
put 450 in a second deal 90 days later
put all the rest of my capital 100
percent of all my money plus 90 grand in
three real estate deals
those are the first three investments I
ever made no the first three or four
investments that made my entire life
three of the four did the little one did
[Music]
the little one couldn't work it's
impossible to work it was too small
what's he gonna do it's not gonna do
anything it's like going into a casino
and you bet $15
right he get blackjack so what is still
$15 did the first thing you're gonna say
is dude I should have bet everything but
she didn't she didn't even be in there
and rule number 10 the last home before
a very special bonus clip is be obsessed
Nevada jet was something I never dreamed
I'd dude I never okay I only started
thinking about it four or five years ago
when I'm young and broke I'm growing up
in Louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you got a bite you be grateful
you got clothes on your back and you get
three meals be grateful for all that you
got cuz you got it better than I do I
never dreamed to have mom damn cheese
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot you do it you borrow
money okay use money if it requires
money so be it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results you know the secret to
sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything that drains you or causes
you doubt money power fame success all
all of them follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power Fame and success even
time off they require attention they're
like jealous lovers they need constant
attention or they're gonna leave you how
you invest your time is more important
than how you invest your money being
obsessed with your sense of purpose
across every part of your life will
allow you to accomplish all the things
you desire I think most people are not
accomplishing what they want in one area
life because they quit on all the other
ones if you quit allow the other ones
how you gonna get this one to run
nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people who have
achieved more than I have and then
meeting new people
I need the obsess must surround
themselves with people you trust and
respect who think big who've done bigger
than you and who can help you get to
where you want to go you think you can
run only so fast time is no longer an
excuse because the obsess make time they
don't make excuses
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from grant on how to expand your network
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching a video to actually
taking some kind of action in your life
or your business so answer these three
questions on your own at home talk about
them with a friend or leave the answers
in the comments below here we go
question number one what do you need to
aim higher on in your life or your
business question number two what
negativity do you need to get rid of and
question number three what poverty
behavior will you lose this week thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
expand your network okay Jim Rohn said
you were the equivalent of the five
people you spend most time with folks if
you don't have your money right the
people you should spend your time with
is customers now you're family now
you're friends unless your friends are
buying from you your family's buying
from you you should spend your five the
five people you spend your time with
every day should be different people
they should be customers after that to
create a network you need to expand
outside of your zip code you need new
friends you need to collaborate with
people you need new connections new
ideas expand a network okay you do not
need more time with your family you need
less time with your family and more time
with a bigger family my wife and I
always talk about let's expand our
family beyond the people that we were
born with I need new ideas I need new
think I needed to know about new parts
of the world a new expansion raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion not
one drop of most self-worth depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details